>> Hey, YouTube.
Umm, how you doing?
My name's Rich Gelfond.
I'm co-CEO of Imax Corporation, those big
screens and kinda cool
movies all over the world and I'm here in
Davos, umm, trying figure
out different ways to make it a better place
and if I had to what's
the one thing I wish would happen in 2008
is increased awareness about
the urgency of the environmental problem.
I'm one of those guys that never gets that
worked up in the present
and I always think there's lots of time to
deal with something but I
have been to Greenland I have seen some of
the melting of the polar
icecaps.
Uh, the story yesterday in the whole Tribune
and mercury poisoning and
its effect on people, uh, food stocks and
what's happening and I think
everybody -- it's just human nature -- kinda
has a tendency to say,
oh, we'll get to it tomorrow.
Don't worry about it but I think the kinda
thing Al Gore's been
talking about is putting it on the agenda
and making sure that people
understand that the environment isn't something
-- it's just gonna be
worse tomorrow, it's not gonna be better,
and we all need to focus on
it and we need to come together as a world
and solve the problem
otherwise, you know, our legacy is gonna be
a barren place.
Thanks, YouTube.